well let's speak to the former treasury
minister and former housing secretary
robert jenner mr generic always great to
see you thanks for joining us on this
budget day who's going to be better off
today
well i think there's an uncertain
picture across the world with inflation
with shortages and issues that the
chancellor have to contend with but as
your report just said there are reasons
for optimism unemployment in particular
is much lower than people expected and
the british economy is growing it's
going to be the fastest growing of any
g7 economy so i think that does give the
chancellor some room room for two things
really firstly for some more investment
in public services to tackle the cost of
living and a proper plan to grow the
economy as we move forwards but he's
going to have to balance that with the
need to be fiscally responsible because
of that continued uncertainty and i
think that's the backdrop which the
chancellor has been considering in the
weeks that have preceded the budget
so who's going to be better off today
well i think we're we're all going to be
better off in the sense that it looks
like the opr forecasts are going to show
that the economy has grown substantially
therefore we're less we're borrowing
much less money as a country and that
gives some more room for the chancellor
to invest in the future of public
services which we all depend on like the
nhs but i think he's also going to have
to think carefully about those people on
the most modest incomes and how he can
help them to whether what's undoubtedly
still going to be a difficult period
when we're seeing inflation rising
higher energy prices and so on
you've seen that in some of the
announcements that have already been
made like the decision to increase the
national living wage which is going to
lead to an increase in wages for about
two million people across the country
and the decision to move to a more
normal period for public sector workers
as well so that there won't be a a
freeze there but the pay review bodies
will be deciding in the months to come
what's a sensible and affordable
increase in wages for that six million
people right across the country so i
think it's striking that balance
along with as i say
continuing to be fiscally prudent
because we just don't know what the
future holds and inflation means the
risk of interest rate rises okay and
that's very costly given that we're all
into the chancellor's books sure given
that we're all going to be better off um
public sector workers are going to get
an above inflation pay rise
well we don't know and we can't say that
yet can we to be fair to the chancellor
everybody's going to get it it's got to
be higher than inflation hasn't it
well the way that public sector pay is
set in this country is by pay review
bodies who then advise the relevant
government department through a proper
process and those are independent bodies
that include trade unionists business
people experts as i think what the
chancellor is going to say is that we're
able as a result of the growing economy
to move into a more normal period that
means that he's going to be asking those
pay review bodies to come forward with
their proposals and then he'll consider
those all the relevant government
departments will consider them next year
so i don't think he'll be in the
position to say exactly uh what you
would like him to say just yet but
that's going to be a few months off
so people just have to wait a bit longer
but yeah i think as a result of it
has been managed
last year just let me say and you can of
course override those pay review bodies
as we all know if that's what you choose
to do either more in favor of the
workers or less as indeed we saw last
year unless it is above inflation pay
rise you said everybody's going to be
better off unless it's an above impact
inflation pay rise then we're not all
going to be better off are we
well i said that i think there'll be
good news across the board for the
economy and for members of public
because we'll be able to invest more in
public services and be more fiscally
prudent so that we've got some
protection built into the economy should
there be shocks down the line i think it
is good news given the cost of living
challenge that we have right now that we
are going to be able to increase wages
uh either through the national living
wage going up that's a very significant
development probably the most
significant one because that's going to
lead to the people who are on the lowest
wages many of whom are within the public
sector like care workers for example but
others across the board those people are
going to be seeing a pay rise of around
six and a half percent that's very
significant increase and really welcome
given what's happening uh for the cost
of living we were all good the public
says that's what you said
i think i think we're just going i think
we're all just going to have to wait and
see what the pay review bodies report
back and there'd be no point
circumventing that process given that
it's been set up in that way
why is the gender pay gap still at 7.9
according to the ons office for national
statistics i mean that has been illegal
since 1970 it's increased during the
pandemic why is this government still
condoning men being paid more than women
well the government doesn't condone men
being paid it's against the law what are
you doing about it
it's been against the law for a very
long time and we've been bearing down
upon it there are structural issues
within the economy about the different
types of jobs that sometimes men and
women do but we as a government have
been trying to tackle this for a long
time it is coming down uh it has been
coming down over the course of the last
10 years but it's still unacceptable
over the last year you and i have gone
up it's gone up over the last year it's
increased to 7.9 percent
well that may be the case over the last
year but the longer term trend is is
downwards uh but i'm not i'm not here to
defend that absolutely not it's
completely wrong we want to see more
women in the workplace and those who've
been properly rewarded for the work that
they do and it's for employers uh to
make sure that they're doing that yeah
but it's also against the law and it has
been for 50 years so you would have
hoped that perhaps it would have gone by
now but let's wait and see
test and trace has been described by the
pm as world beating a parliamentary
investigation says it's an eye-watering
waste of taxpayers money which is it
well i've seen the reporting on the the
public accounts committee's work this
morning and that's something i'm
certainly going to to read it is very
concerning what they've said on the
other hand it is a program that i think
has led to 320 million tests being done
over the course of the last year and a
year and a bit uh 20 million people have
been contacted so it has played an
important part in tackling the pandemic
are there lessons that can and must be
learned from it i think absolutely and
we're all going to have to pay
particularly the government to what's
said by the public accounts committee
okay slightly running out of time so i
can't press you further on that but what
i can ask you about is our most
important diplomat her majesty she is
not going to be at cop 26. the pm said
to a group of kids in downing street
it's touch and go if cop 26 will be a
success and he is very worried about it
given that her majesty is now also not
going how
much do you think it's going to be a
success or a failure what's the
likelihood
well firstly like you i said my best
wishes to her majesty the queen i know
she would have liked to have been at cop
and she's going to be doing a video
message it's much more important that
she puts her own health and well-being
first
but as regards cop well i think there is
a lot more work to be done i've seen
alex sharma has been meeting chinese
representatives in the last 24 hours we
need to ensure that those countries who
are the biggest global emitters
come to the table and there will be a
lot of last minute wrangling and
negotiation to be done i don't think the
prime minister or indeed alex sharma
could have done more than they have in
terms of trying to corral global
nations to take action and there has
been some significant progress in the
last couple of days i think for example
scott morrison in australia making a
significant step to some extent saudi
arabia although it's it's to a slower
trajectory than we would have wanted but
you can see progress but a lot more now
needs to be achieved just in a couple of
days
okay
finally before i let you go why are
masks mandatory for all staff in the
house of commons contractors press and
third parties but not for mps
i i don't know is the honest answer to
that okay i mean that's a decision i
think by the house
authorities or the speaker who issued
those guidelines uh it doesn't seem
right to me that there's one rule for
everyone else who works in the building
but not for members of parliament i
think we will have to change our
behavior accordingly i wore a mask when
i was voting last night uh through the
pack division lobbies i think we'll all
have to consider wearing a mask in the
coming days
and will you wear one for the budget
i i think i will yeah because it will be
a busy occasion lots of people tightly
packed
i i don't think that as members of
parliament we can ask something
different of our staff and the people
who work in the building than we're
doing ourselves
mr generic i'm so sorry i can't talk to
you in person it's always much more fun
doing that forgive me uh for
interrupting you on occasion it's always
a little bit tricky isn't it when it's
down the line it's a pleasure talking to
you we'll see you very soon hopefully
thank you
nice to see you bye now